they make it their business to mind your
business
Vancouver has banned doorknobs to
improve accessibility homes will have to
be built with lubbers instead and there
will be no more MIT frat parties in
Boston the van comes after a fraternity
member injured himself after falling
through a skylight during the party but
this time the nation's top Nags can be
found in Bartow Florida code enforcement
says the signs are illegal they say
they've got to come out of the ground or
residents will face fines these have
been doing some lawn since the fourth of
July but now officials say the signs
have got to go here have a signed
violation please remove the temporary
signs from the property temporary signs
have been illegal for over a decade but
the band hasn't been an issue until now
officials say the ordinance has nothing
to do the content of the signs but some
residents are outraged the ban exists at
all this is my yard so I'm paying the
taxes on and it's my rot the City
backpedaled after facing public outrage
now the signs may stick around while
officials review the ordinance and the
city may end up scrapping the ban
following a knee the month on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees can click
here to watch another episode
you
[Music]